another new trailer thanks marvel at
this point we'll be able to see the
whole movie before it comes out oh but I
can't tell you one thing and it's a bit
of a secret anyway big secrets in all
seriousness this trailer has some
amazing news scenes one in particular
and it's really short so if you're not
paying attention you might miss it here
we go watch carefully now I know it
feels like old hope is lost together
we can't stop fans I think we'll pass
just kid we're it
ready I'm Peter by the way dr. strange
Oh using your made-up names then I am
spider-man did you see it
probably not so here's the trailer again
for you did you catch it it's not even a
second long it's like a half second long
but here it is in slow mode for you if
you look closely at his right hand
you'll notice that he has a sword if
you're not familiar with Iron Man's new
bleeding-edge armor suit what you
basically need to know is that it's made
out of millions of tiny little nano
machines these little nano machines form
around Tony's body to make his suit and
they turn into whatever he thinks of or
commands them to and this scene he
clearly has them turned into a sword I'm
so excited to see this scene in theaters
and find out what it's all about
did he form the sword in midair did he
form it on the ground and then take off
who's he using it against Thanos I'm
here for a fight scene between Thanos
and Iron Man with a sword I guess we'll
have to wait till April 27th to find out
there's a few other new scenes in here
and the first one starts off with some
new words spoken by Thor to the
guardians of the galaxy we believe he
says now I know it feels like all hope
is lost but together we can stop the
nose then it shows us a new scene of
rocket that we haven't seen before where
he says I think we'll pass just kidding
we're in I actually don't think this is
rocket replying to what Thor just said
I'm sure Marvel wants us to think that
but I think this is just two clips taken
from the movie combined for the trailer
either way we know that the guardians of
the galaxy pick up Thor in mid-space
after Thanos just wipes the floor with
him
Loki and the Hulk this is why Thor is
saying I know it feels like all hope is
lost and considering the fact that
Thanos just kicked his butt and Thor
seems to think that there's still a way
to even stand a chance against Thanos it
makes me feel like Stormbreaker is gonna
be a heck of a weapon besides that
nothing else tuned you got a pretty cool
clip of Captain America opening his new
shield and a really cool clip of Doctor
Strange working as mystic Artes and
that's about it
the trailers not long but it's really
cool that we got to see a scene of Iron
Man holding a sword what do you guys
think of this new trailer what do you
guys think of Iron Man holding a sword
let me know in the comments below and
please be sure to like this video and
subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date on Avengers infinity war Marvel and
everything
superhero thank you so much for watching
woof woof